Oh my goodness, my voice is still...
My voice is a little icky.
It has been two weeks since I last played.
So I apologize if I forgot some stuff.
But I recently had my...
Is she singing?
Wait, that's so awesome.
Wait, that's so cute!
Okay, sorry.
I have my 3D jazz...
What is 3D jazz show?
And...
And then afterwards, you would think...
You would think, oh, her voice must be so worn out from
doing two live jazz shows.
No, no, no.
I went to Disney.
I went on one of my favorite rides.
Actually, oh my gosh.
I was so lucky.
One of my favorite rides at the park is called Rise of the
Resistance.
And it's so good.
And it was down.
It was like scheduled to be down for my date that I was
going.
And I was like, no.
And it said like not sure when it would be back up.
But then two days.
Two days before I went, it went.
back up and so I was able to ride it again and so I was very
very very happy about that and I yelled and um I went on all
my favorite rides and I was very very excited and I get
excited and I go whoa whoa whoa on rides so I lost my voice
a little bit sorry but we're back to portal 2 I've been
non-stop wanting to get back into it so I'm very excited
let's see um so yeah I'm recording this what day is it the
18th of February and exactly two weeks ago we were on
chapter 6 the fall so for you guys it was maybe not so long
ago but for me I will have to get back into the swing of
things so let's get back into it Lord Lord
Yippee!
I think I remember where I ended.
Yes!
Well, I came from this way, no?
Wait.
I think so.
Okay, okay.
All right, we got our sticky goo here.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, gosh, oh, gosh,
I'm making a mess.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
I like to just kind of spread it everywhere.
Did I call it sticky goo?
I think I meant my bouncy goo.
Ah, let's see.
I have a button here.
We need to get this bat boy out.
Oh!
That doesn't work.
Um, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh We're getting a feel of the
environment.
There's this up here too.
Oh, Hawaii.
I'm mixing the juices.
Ah-ha!
Ah!
Might be a safety hazard.
Okay, please.
Oh, I need to rinse you off, though.
You're going to be bouncing everywhere.
Is it thoroughly clean?
How do I get to do?
Oh, vouch.
Wait.
Oh, my.
Um.
Can I add some more bounce to my?
A little more pep to my step.
Oh, you look so close.
What are you for?
I really just like covering the floors in it.
Shower me.
Okay.
How do I get up there?
Very curious.
Oh.
Oh, geez.
I'm just waiting.
I think I'm stuck.
Okay, good.
I want to rock it back and forth.
I want to swing.
Okay, I'm getting distracted.
I'm getting distracted.
Oh, can't I just...
But like at the same time, I need to be able to get over to
there that's my issue though that's my main issue
hmm and then once I get up there how do I move this it is
not so simple if I do something like does
it knock it off okay what if I did oh okay I would Okay,
okay.
Ah, oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait.
Okay.
Alright.
Let's just stop all that nonsense real quick.
Alright, so that's how I would...
Okay, but I would need to have this set up here.
Oops, oops!
Oh!
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
Oh yeah.
I could somehow jump over, use the jumpy.
Let's see.
It's just not enough.
Push.
Run and pooh!
Oh, it is enough!
It is enough!
Just kidding!
Okay, it's like here.
Uh, there?
Science isn't about why.
It's about why not!
Why is so much of our science dangerous?
Why not Mary save science if you love it so much?
In fact, why not invent a special safety door?
Cave Johnson!
You are on the way out because you are fire!
Now you test subject.
You're doing much.
Oh, okay, thank you.
You box your stuff.
Out the front door.
Parking lot, car.
Goodbye.
Some of the things that they put in there feel like red
herrings, no?
Sorry, I look over because I'm...
I don't remember where I had my audio at before.
Hooky-dokie!
Congratulations.
The simple fact that you're standing here listening to me
means you've made a glorious contribution to science.
As founder and CEO of Aperture Science, I thank you for your
participation.
and hope we can count on you for another round of tests.
We're not going to release this stuff into the wild until
it's good and damn ready.
So as long as you keep yourself in top physical form, there
will always be a limo waiting for you.
Say goodbye, Carolyn.
Goodbye, Carolyn.
She is a gem.
Well, we're back in the...
Oh, thank you for your participation.
I did it.
Is this...
I feel like I in my head I'm imagining that guy from
Dispatch the not not not the skinny skinny legend um that's
from Amaman that's who I'm imagining in my head saying
everything okay so this is not a door and this this is not
an elevator to the surface and I though I do need a surface
Tollable.
I spoke it into existence.
Two hands.
Where are we now?
So I'm not in the testing anymore, so...
What are we doing?
What are we doing now?
I'm scared.
The gel.
Actually, I don't even remember why I'm down here.
Oh no.
I don't remember.
I need to get up there.
What physics am I using?
None.
Just kidding.
Just a tiny...
Oh, tiny.
Yeah, there we go.
All right.
Wait, what's the red gel?
We got the blue gel.
Oh, we need to get up there.
There it is.
Do I use the force to break the glass with my body?
Let's see.
Ouch.
Okay, never mind.
I don't use the force to break it with my body.
Anyway.
That was funny, wasn't it?
Get a good laugh at that one.
Wait, though.
Where do I put the portal?
To launch me over here.
I'm forgetting the basics of the game.
Okay, wait.
Okay, we got to do multiple physics of things.
Okay, I just got to notice what the order of operations is
here.
I don't see another wall.
That's my issue.
Am I blind?
Like I was in the last one?
Was I blind?
I mean, I was blind.
Am I blind again?
No.
Oh, I think I get it.
I think I get it.
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
So I go through here.
I'll launch.
I'll hit orange.
And then...
Okay, okay.
Orange!
I got it.
What's in here?
Pump station beta.
Oh!
I'm doing things and I don't know what I'm doing.
Is that a good thing or?
Okay.
Oh, we're outside.
Control room.
Music is epic again.
Ooh.
Whoa!
Sorry, he just scared me.
The orb.
Is it filled with goo?
Greetings, friend.
I'm Cave Johnson, CEO of Amateur Science.
You might know us as a vital participant in the 1968 Senate
hearings on missing astronauts.
And you've most likely used one of the many products we
invented, but that other people have somehow managed to
steal from us.
Black Mesa can eat my bankrupt...
Sir, the testing?
Now you might be asking yourself, Cave, just how difficult
are these tests?
What was in that phone book of a contract I signed?
Am I in danger?
Let me answer those questions with a question.
Who wants to make $60?
Cash.
Me!
You can also feel free to relax for up to 20 minutes in the
waiting room, which is a damn site more comfortable than the
parked benches most of you were sleeping on when we found
you.
So, welcome to Aperture.
You're here because we want the best, and you're it.
Nope.
Couldn't keep a straight face.
$60!
In fact, why don't you just go ahead and not touch anything
unless it's test related?
Oh yeah, cash in hand, baby.
Is this the waiting room?
I think they'd be able to afford actual benches or
something.
Wow, this is how they lived.
Remember, alert your supervisor if you see an OSHA
inspector.
inspector gala accountant undercover police officer how
would you know nuclear regulatory commissioner FEMA
coordinator ordinary police officer journalist public works
inspector msha mine inspector ATF FBI US Marshal we're doing
completely legal and ethical trainings and experiments and
conduct conduct conduct conductions here cave Johnson you've
changed so much all right let's go just kidding let's not go
there let's go up there I suppose why does a wood not allow.
I'm looking for a wall.
Oh, no.
Is that how you want me to do it?
I think that's how they want me to do it.
Wait.
Oh, there we go.
Oh.
Okay, we're good.
Can't ever be an easy staircase with these guys now, can it?
No, no.
Never.
Oh, wait.
Why do I need to launch, actually?
I'm already here.
Where does wanted me to launch to.
I guess we'll figure it out.
There's nothing in here.
One thing I do kind of...
Okay, this is so, like...
So indie horror game-brained of me.
But...
I almost wish that there were, like, little notes hidden
around.
But, like, kind of... Not, gave...
Not, like...
You see an orange jumpsuit?
Hit the red button.
But I...
I'm in an orange jumpsuit!
It's like a prisoner outfit.
But yeah, it's like, you know how indie horror games will
have like, Dear Diary.
This is my diary from from 30 years ago and I'm explaining
every thought and feeling.
I don't want that, but you know, just like a little hidden
extra stuff, I think is fine.
It's my only thing.
Where am I going?
Ouch.
Where am I?
Am I...
What?
Am I trying to go to here?
Okay.
Let's do that.
Oh, wait.
Ah!
Excuse you.
Please let me back up.
Wait.
Yeah, maybe I'm trying to get into that controller room.
Okay, okay.
I went the wrong.
Hmm.
perhaps.
Oh, geez.
Let's try.
Oh, it's so close.
To be fair, it was hard to tell from up here where I was
going.
All right.
You...
No, I did the wrong one here.
Okay, that's fine.
Wait!
Oh, hi.
Gladys!
The part that stole you.
I'm watching.
You're in the potato.
It's eating me.
And then it's gonna eat her.
Oh, my god.
Okay, okay.
Just get it off me.
Oh, thanks.
Or then it's gonna eat me.
Wait, I got that.
Did you feel that?
was from blowing up and let you go okay
that's true i don't like this anymore than you do in fact i
like
you still look great you still look great oh
she's on my god now
why is the bird nest on the button that is to the elevator
control Ow, ow, ow.
If I think too hard...
Ew.
Alright.
Let's do up there.
Probably.
Wee!
Woo!
Oh.
Ah!
Did I miss a button?
Um, how?
Do I need to go higher?
There we go.
Yeah, you can't stop me, you stupid kid.
Yeah!
Where are we going?
To the surface?
I forgot about the loading screens.
live right it's a chapter 7 the testing area is just up
ahead the quicker you get through the quicker you'll get
your 60 bucks 60 bucks 60 bucks
he even controls GLaDOS his voice I need to become mr.
Johnson to control Wheatley I'm in
What's this do?
Okay, thank you for keeping our enrichment spheres clean!
Who's up there?
What is up here?
Nothing.
Oh, just kidding.
A button.
Wait, it's the red goo!
Orange goo.
What does this one do?
Oh,
it makes me the fast goo!
It's the fast goo!
Let's get back up there.
I forgot about this one.
Wow, my aim is impeccable.
Shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot, shoot!
Yay, so very good.
All right.
We're running, we're running, we're running.
I can make it.
Oh, did I see me poking out from over there?
Watch, watch.
Oh, ow!
Oh, oh.
Look.
That's my booty.
Okay.
I'm glad I assumed that was going to be the thing to do.
I'm glad I assumed that.
Oh, wait.
I need more goo.
Um...
Let's go back.
I'm gonna get out of there.
Oh, whoops, wrong one.
That's fine though.
And then we do...
Ah!
I thought I was the wrong one.
Oh shoot.
Okay, hold on.
I messed up.
All right, let's go back and set...
All right, we'll set...
Blue here.
Blue.
Oh,
well we can do this.
Okay, so then...
It's just order of operations, everybody.
Order of operations.
Alright, then we do orange here.
Right?
Yeah.
Yes!
Slime the whole hallway!
I guess I could have run through that, but it's fine.
Oh
Speed run, speed run, speed run, wait, I need to get up
there Oh, ow, wait that makes sense because Yes, yes, yes,
yes, I wonder if I do the super ultra long hallway.
All right, here we go.
Yeah!
Up.
What's that mean?
Okay, well, I'm here.
Okay, let's see.
Do not leave your belongings here.
Loiter for more than 20 minutes, touch the glass.
They're very adamant about not touching the glass.
Do wear a shirt and shoes at all times.
But no pants!
Move quickly through your test track!
Do not forget to not touch the glass.
They make me want to touch it.
Alright, let's see what to do here.
My only issue is how do I get back home?
I guess I could do this, so if I...
There's something of the swords.
Oh!
Ah!
Wait!
Oh!
Let me out!
Let me out, please!
Please!
There we go.
Yippee!
We do it.
I guess emotional outbursts require more than 1.6 volts.
Now we know that.
We just need to relax.
We're still going to find out what the hell's going on here,
but calmly.
Calmly, meditative.
No stress.
Is there something?
The music coming and going is so funny.
I discover the secrets.
Those people in the portrait, they look so familiar.
Oh, I got an achievement for that.
Find a hidden portrait.
Cave Johnson.
Is that Carolyn?
Ooh, three phones.
They look familiar.
Cave Johnson.
I find the secrets.
Can I go back through?
Oh, you can.
Okay.
Let's see.
What do we have here?
And we got...
Oh, we got blue goo.
We got orange goo.
We've got the whole goo.
I don't know why I did that.
I just like to cover the place.
Wow.
The VTuber Bath Waters.
It's truly... it's in great production.
Alright, let's see here.
So there's this.
What does it do?
Yo, even if I bounce, can I mix the goose?
Or is it one controls... one covers the other?
Okay, one covers the other.
I figured that would be the case, but...
Okay.
Then we have these panels here.
Do these?
No.
Whoa.
That
was a mild miscalculation on my part.
Oh!
Wait, I just noticed this one, too.
Okay.
If I run and jump, if I do like a super speedy and then and
then here Like so It should be enough, I think All right,
all right, all right
Maybe overkill Do I have to do the same thing here?
Actually, let's see.
Wait on there.
I can see a thing up there.
I need to fling myself, I believe.
But from where?
Once... once moment?
Heh heh heh heh.
Am I inside the dome?
Whoa, I just noticed.
Okay, anyway.
Where?
Am I missing a part that I have not seen?
Where or where?
Let's say, um...
I'm trying to look at any of the platforms that I can hit
right now.
This one's dumping me a little.
I like the music.
Maybe I'm overthinking it somehow.
I tend to do that, right?
Okay,
yeah, I don't think so.
I don't know, some part of me is just like, can I fall, but
there's not a way.
What the heck you?
What am I supposed to do here?
Is there anything below here that I missed?
I don't think it would be like a blue girl here or anything.
Can I...
Oh, wait.
The wall over here.
No.
I was gonna say, like, can I run real fast and...
Eh?
Yeah!
Which one is that one?
Wait, am I...
Okay, yeah.
Oh my gosh, can I get stuck in the grate?
Oh.
I'm stuck!
No, I'm actually stumped though.
Like, that doesn't work.
These don't work.
There's nothing below me that I can fall into.
I'm trying to
think of how I can use the goose, but...
I don't think Okay, wait If I, maybe like a Hold on, if I
drop here No, I think even if I like Cover this in blue goo
I think it's not I'm like I shouldn't even be alive right
now Eh
Let me try going back over here Let's see If there's
anything else that I could see over here.
What the heck?
There's always, I feel like every...
I like the music.
Every part, there's always one thing that gets me.
This might be my one for this part that gets me out.
I got it!
I got it.
I think.
Oh, if I go through there, okay, okay, okay.
If I go, if I go me- into there, I can do it.
I can do it.
Okay, okay, okay.
All right, I got it.
I figured it out.
I am a genius.
Wait, I need to get up there first.
See, it just needed a new pursuit.
perspective.
Nah!
Ah!
Okay, wait, I need to...
Oh, I need to get the right angle first.
That's awkward.
Okay, okay.
All right, all right.
All right.
I'm in the middle.
I'm smack dab in the middle.
Thank you!
You're a hero and or Olympian.
We're gonna change the world.
Hey, listen up down there.
That thing's called an elevator.
Not a bathroom.
I swear I know him.
Who's using it as a bathroom?
I think you would, Glados.
I want, like, a little Glados potato.
Now, you know?
I want my own Glados potato.
When I first got into Portal, though, I wanted the gun so
bad like a prop of the gun did they ever make official
versions or were they always just handmade i wonder if
you're interested in an additional 60 flag down a test
associate and let them know okay you could walk out of here
with 120 weighing down your bindle if you let us take you
apart put some science stuff in you then put you back
together good as new i love science stuff and science size
oh yeah give me that blue goo oh yeah give me that orange
glue goo this has arrows
we got one single one baby cover that up that was a week
that was a week come on keep Yeah, there we go, there we go,
there we go.
Now where do I need to go?
I think I actually don't have any...
Oh, wow, there's...
Oh, wow, there is so much going on here.
Oh, what?
Okay, let's go around and...
Oh, my bud.
Let's go around.
I wasted some.
I'm the worst.
Okay, so there's this here.
Okay, this will be imperative for launch.
Okay, we need to get some, like, crazy momentum.
Probably this button makes it so that I can bounce.
Or rather, we have to make it so that it has a bouncy on it,
I think.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So I, like, run, run, speed, bounce, I think.
that they have in mind.
And then there's a box over here.
How do I get this guy?
Alright, there's so much going on here.
I think I may be it.
Oh, whoops.
Take it.
Can I launch myself over this?
Let's see if we can get the box this way.
Ha!
Woo!
Oh, I need the...
I need to bounce there.
Okay, okay.
All right.
This is definitely a test of order of operations kind of
situation.
You?
If I flow it there, will it launch to...
Oh, it does.
Perfect.
Let me get over there first.
Alright.
Ooh, this sounds so rickety.
Are we safe here?
Woo!
We're fine!
Talk about rickety.
Holy cow.
Okay.
Nice.
Alright, we'll send you.
Over here.
Yes, sir.
Right there.
But how?
Sorry.
Oh, shoot.
I see.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's one more for safe measure, okay.
Wow!
All
right.
So that's that, and then I'm in here.
I think that might be it, actually.
Let's do...
That, right, that, like that, right quick.
That might be it.
Master the propulsion, Joe.
All you gotta do is let us disassemble you.
We're not banging rocks together here.
We know how to put a man back together.
That one was easy.
New vitals, spit shine on the old ones, plus we're scooping
out tumors frankly you ought to be paying us we're scooping
out tumors oh no that tumor
i what if i like mine it's my noggin
okay dokey let's see what's our next challenge i thought we
were done with the experiments oh believe i'm thanking these
people for staggering your way through aperture sciences
propulsion gel testing you've made some real contributions
to society for a change and for that humanity is grateful if
you had any belongings please pick them up now we don't want
old newspapers and sticks cluttering up the building sticks
are many of you i realize sixty dollars is an unprecedented
windfall so don't go spending it all on i don't know carolyn
what are these people buying Beard hats.
Beard dirt.
Cave Johnson, you've changed.
Cave Johnson, you've changed!
I thought you were one of us!
You never were.
Okay.
I'm just looking around.
Very cool.
The scope of this place is crazy.
Thank you for not loitering longer than 20 minutes.
I think they hate us, maybe.
I think I'm learning that.
what are these chairs for my belongings please all forms
must be filled out allegedly and completely before eligible
to receive payment of sixty dollars how much was it before
our arm I'm noticing that it appears that there was a
different amount surely it was probably only like five
dollars before And they were like, no, it's too low.
These, they're good people.
We must raise it to 60.
Please excuse the inconvenience.
This elevator is out of service until blank.
Oh, wait.
Oh, okay.
I just noticed.
I forgot we went through this thing up here.
Oh, it's around here.
Ooh, what's going on here?
a whole lot of nothing actually wait what is happening there
oh oh well um that's that's it for that i suppose
uh gamma wasn't oh there it is i was like i wasn't looking
high enough gamers don't look up
Watch yourself.
What's in here?
Or more.
Or?
Oh my god.
Is it your mom?
Look, you're doing a great job.
Can you help?
It's your mom.
Carolyn, Carolyn, Carolyn.
What are we gonna do about Carolyn?
What are we gonna do in here?
What is going on in here?
Oh yeah, more gel, more gel!
Give me all the gel!
Oh, oh wait, that's scary.
Oh, oh no.
Oh.
Yeah, I don't want to deal with that, anyway.
My ears.
Oh, we're just leaking gel.
Yeah, what's here?
Wait, what is the white gel for?
This one's new!
Ooh, I'm covered.
And...
Tony.
Let's see.
I'm
gonna look from up here.
What does the white gel do?
Does not say.
I'm observing.
Oh, there's more hydraulic presses up there.
What is it?
Seems that's where we need to go, no?
So...
Does it make any surface?
Oh, it makes any surface!
A portal bubble surface!
Right, that's so awesome!
I love white gel!
Uh-oh.
Oh!
Fine, we're fine.
Carla, the complainer, says, My new boss is a robot!
But did you know?
Robots are smarter than you?
Robots work harder than you?
Robots are better than you?
Volunteer for testing today.
Word.
I don't know if I like how Gladys is right now.
She seems too like a wieny, you know?
Can I jump down from here or something?
Do I blue glue here?
Oh it's off!
I couldn't do it anyway.
How do I get to the other side?
How do I... Is there a wall?
Oh, wait.
Maybe...
Like, here?
Wait, where did I come from?
Was I down there, I think?
How...
Where did I come from here?
Where did I come from?
Oh!
Oopsie.
My bad.
I guess it makes sense.
She is just a potato right now.
inside.
I don't blame her.
I don't blame you.
Bird, bird!
Maybe like that.
I can't, oh wait, wait.
I can't tell where I'm supposed to try.
No, maybe.
Oops.
I'm trapped.
Stop, stop.
I don't think I need to go down here.
This is where I came from.
Wait, I don't remember where I came from.
Or this is where I came from.
So I need to go over here?
Let me see.
No.
Sometimes the dumbest things trip me up, I swear.
I swear, sometimes I feel like I'm getting got by the
stupidest things.
There's no thing for me to launch my own.
myself with, so...
Hot water,
but...
There's nothing in here to help me with.
My new boss is a robot!
Oh!
Yes, there is!
You know, I did notice that wall, and I was just like, oh, I
wonder if this will help out, and then And in my brain, I
was like, oh, that was too late.
In my brain, I was like, no.
That's like, that's how they got the gel up there.
They portaled it up there.
That's what my brain was saying.
I think probably the angled one would be better.
Woo.
Welcome to the enrichment center.
Oh, he sounds different, yeah.
Since making test participation mandatory for all employees,
the quality of our test subjects has risen dramatically.
Employee retention, however, has not.
As a result, you may have heard we're going to phase out
human testing.
There's still a few things left to wrap up, though.
The bean counters told me we literally could not afford to
buy $7 worth of moon rocks, much less $70 million.
Bottom anyway, round them up, mix them into a gel.
And guess what?
up moon rocks are pure poison i am deathly ill still it
turns out they're a great portal conductor so now we're
gonna see if jumping in and out of these new portals can
somehow lead to lunar poison out of a man's bloodstream well
i give you so close make lemonade let's all stay positive
and do some science that said i would really appreciate it
if you could test as fast as possible
Johnson, what has happened to you?
Me and my enemy girlfriend.
Oh my gosh.
They just destroyed themselves.
Aperture science.
What have you done?
Wow.
So cool.
Robots don't sleep.
They can test and do your job.
Volunteer for testing today.
Wait for attendant.
Please do not test if you are allergic to lunar sediment and
or starch.
You have fulfilled your monthly test self-election quota.
You are confident enough in your work performance to
unvolunteer from the test self-election process.
Okay.
Let's go in, baby.
And I think...
Oh.
Is this where we ended today?
Perhaps.
I want to see what happens.
Are we going to the surface?
Nope.
Waiko!
Yippee!
Alright.
Everything will be portable.
Wait.
whole area has no port is a bubbles areas uh-oh that's why
we go the way wait that's why we do the way we go yay wow
thank you guys for well i guess we'll do this puzzle in the
next one i'm excited to work with the white goo now it looks
Like, chunkier than the other goose.
Is it just me?
I like how it's still very slowly spreading.
Very slowly.
Reaching new parts.
Oh, there, there, there, there, there, there, there, there,
yeah, yeah.
Expand.
Thank you guys for Today's Portal 2 I'll see you in the next
one
Bye-bye Bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye-bye